so this guy Bradman rock is a Filipino
beauty influencer hello hello he does
this interview with this guy Zach
singing for the life of me I can't fully
understand what is transpiring between
both of them what do I want to do on the
screens just the breadman rock
Shenanigans honestly girl if I if me and
my chickens could walk across that
screen actually let me just pitch my
shot right now Moana I would love to be
the chicken I I just fully don't
understand culture at the moment life is
good
um back home not so much you know with
everything going on in Maui prayers to
Maui
um yeah
there's nothing better than just the
obligate yes prayers to Maui this no
good like girl if my chickens could get
on the iMac screen prayers to Maui and
then he immediately changed like there's
nothing better than the immediate
reversal where the interviewer was like
no I know it's just